Okay. So we are in lecture number 11.
This is the penultimate lecture from my
side. So the last lecture from my side
is next week and then after that uh
David Grabber talks about AI for
chemistry and biology. So we change
perspective. Okay. So the journey is
progressing well. I would say we are
almost coming to the end of what I
wanted to say. So the whole course so
far is to learn physics which are
modeled through PTEES using deep neural
networks. So that's where we are
progressing very well and we focused on
operator learning. So this is learning
the solution operator from data and we
saw so many different examples FNO CNO
different kinds of transformers which
are very effective and very successful
on PDEs on cartitionian domains
essentially 2D but you could scale up to
3D with those without any problems and
we also realized that for doing time
dependent PTE we have different options
we can do all toall training we can do
auto reggressive evaluation auto
reggressive training and so on In the
last lecture, our focus was on PDS in
arbitrary domains. So this is more
engineering related. Uh real world is
not about cartian grids. It's really
about very complex grids, complex point
clouds, domains and so on. And there
were two options GNN's graph neural
networks or a combination of graphs and
transformers. Right? So this was sort of
my recommendation because the problem
with graph neural networks is that they
don't scale well
uh at large scale. that they're okay at
intermediate scale but at very large
scales it's very difficult. So this
already covers a lot of ground but there
are still some remaining caveats two big
ones in my opinion we take one today or
we tackle one today and one in the next
lecture. So what are the remaining
caveats?
So let me start with this. So so far
what we have done is we have looked at
different kinds of PDEs modeling
different kinds of physics but one
essential physics that has been missed
is uh model by PTE with multiscale
and chaotic solutions mean I'm going to
define what both those things are but
you have a sort of intuit not define but
at least formalize what those things are
but you have an intuitive idea of what
it means multiscale means that the
solution itself or the inputs or the
outputs they are structures at different
scales, right? As you would expect in
the real world. And chaotic is
essentially sensitive dependence
nonlinearities, right? Sensitive
dependence to initial conditions. Small
changes in the input lead to large
changes in output. And this is the
regime for many many many interesting
physical phenomena. The most important
one of these is of course fluid flow,
right? Or turbulent fluid flow. So today
what we're going to tackle are these
kind of PDs. We'll see how our current
architectures fit and whether we need to
make a change of perspective. So
remember these two words. These are the
two key words multiscale and chaotic or
highly dependent sensitively dependent
to inputs. Okay. So let me give you an
example just to set things up and I'll
go very slowly today. I don't have a lot
of I don't want to bombard you with a
lot of material. This is difficult
material. So I'll try to keep it concise
and focused. So Navia Stokes. So we all
know what the Navia Stokes equations
are, right? So this is UT plus U. rad u
plus llassian of p equal to new llassian
gradient of p new llassian of u
divergence of u equals 0 and u at x0 is
some initial conditions and I'll assume
today for simplicity that everything is
happening on a unit box okay so you take
the unit cube in 3D right so unit cube
and you put periodic boundary conditions
because we know that when you have
complex grids and complex domains what
are the different options that we have.
So we try to isolate that difficulty and
focus on a different difficulty today.
So these are the Navia Stokes equations
and the interesting thing about Navia
Stokes equations is that fluid flows are
characterized by a non-dimensional
quantity. Uh those who know this
mechanical engineers in particular know
it's called a renol's number
and that determines uh different kinds
of different regimes of flow. I'm not
going into the details of what this
renol's number is but essentially what
happens is if in the morning when you
turn on the sink the tap in the sink
then in the beginning when it's sort of
the flow is slow it's low and all's
number and when you sort of keep on
turning and the flow becomes faster and
faster it is it gets into higher reol's
number and you see that the flow gets
more and more complicated. So what we
are interested is in the realistic
regime which is larger than all number
[snorts] and this is what is typical for
real world flows air and water. These
are the two most important fluids that
we deal with in our lives. Maybe blood
is the third one that is lower and all
number but uh at least air and water
external to us these are large and all
numbers and engineering atmospheric
science uh oceanic science ocean
sciences and astrophysics these are
really in the large and all numbers. So
engineering is typically around a
million to 100 million maybe a billion
uh atmospheric sciences around the same
target uh 100 million to a billion and
in astrophysics it's trillions you know
so this is the regime that we are
interested in and it turns out that the
solution of the Navia Stokes equation it
becomes more and more complicated as the
Renault's number is increased or as the
viscosity means if you remember we also
looked at this before when we were
discussing pin
as the viscosity gets reduced. So as the
viscosity becomes smaller, the number
increases, the flow becomes harder and
harder, the gradients become larger and
uh things become complicated. So we we
remembered that from our pins lectures,
right? As the as the viscosity got
reduced, uh things became harder and
harder to resolve. So what am I showing
you here? I'm showing you a very
canonical set of initial conditions. As
I said, we are on the unit squared. So
the boundary conditions is not an issue.
So you have initial conditions and these
are what are called the Taylor green
vortex. [snorts]
So these were prescribed in the 1930s I
think and the initial conditions are
just sinosoids sum of signs essentially.
But then what happens is that as the
time progresses the flow becomes very
very complicated. So I want to explain a
little what's going on here. So what we
did is that we took this equations.
These are highly nonlinear equations as
you can imagine. there's no chance of
finding analytical solutions. There are
none in this regime.
So we use something called a spectral
viscosity method
which is a numerical method. Okay.
And this was done in my lab by one of my
PhD students. Highly efficient
implementation of this method on GPUs.
And then we used the supercomputer in
Lugano CSCS Alps or this was in Daint I
guess the one before Alps and we
simulated this flow. Okay. At different
resolutions. So there are three figures
that you are seeing here. So what you're
seeing here is the pointwise kinetic
energy.
pointwise kinetic energy that is half of
u ^2 mod u ^2 right so that's the
kinetic energy you have a fluid it has
three components x y and z you take the
squares of each sum them and look at
every single point at a given time mean
this is at t equal to two I think in a
non-normalized units doesn't really
matter so what do you see so look let's
focus on this one so what you see now is
that the solution which just began as a
sum of signs a few signs three or four
sign maybe three I I think I don't
remember exactly you can look it up it
becomes very very complicated by the
time t equal to 2. So what you see here
with the 0.5 wise kinetic energy because
it's a scalar quantity at each point so
we can better visualize it is that the
solution becomes uh has a lot of small
scales right it has a lot of scatter lot
of small scales this is a real flow if
you go and look at the at a river
flowing at high speed or you look at I
don't know if you have seen some
visualizations of air this is what
happens there are small edies small
vortices worlds and so on so it's a very
complex uh flow different uh small scale
features you know the I'm sorry I didn't
put a color bar but I think blue is
negative and uh red is positive so there
are sharp gradients and so on you'll see
that in the next few slides so that's
the first thing so you see that the
solution is very complicated large
gradients and it has lot of structures
lot of small scale structures right so
it has large scales it has uh large
scale structure here it has tiny
structures here so there are range of
scales and we'll characterize that
better so it's It's a complex solution,
right? This is a regime that is
interesting because it corresponds to
what happens in the real world. So
that's one thing remember multiscale. So
this is important multiscale complex
solutions. And what you see here is a
very interesting uh picture. So what we
did is that we took the initial
conditions, right? I don't write the
initial conditions. It's not uh
pertinent to what we are talking about
the exact form of them. But what we did
is that we seeded tiny tiny
perturbations in those initial
conditions. Okay, very tiny
perturbations so tiny that the naked eye
will not be able to perceive it. Right?
So this is because you cannot measure a
fluid state with any sort of precision
there'll be tiny tiny mistakes that you
are going to make. So when you make
these mistakes or when you make this
initial perturbations let's see how the
solution progresses how the differences
in the solution progress. So as you can
see here is one example here is a second
sample here is a third sample. Each of
them is as complex visually and as
complicated contains a range of scales
as the other. So that is what is clear.
But what is also clear is how different
they are means they look qualitatively
the same. But let's try to focus on
let's say this structure this part here.
Right? So in the first flow you can see
that there's a scatter. In the second
flow you see that the location of the
vortices their amplitude is very
different. In the third one you have
very different structures. For instance,
this little filament is here which is
not here which is not here and so on. So
these are really order of one
separations. So the initial conditions
were different by less than 1%. But the
solution itself is different by almost
100%. You know so this is very
characteristic of real world fluids that
you make tiny this is a chaotic system
right this is the definition of a
chaotic system. you make tiny
perturbations and as a consequence of
these perturbations you see that the
outputs because of the nonlinearity. The
mechanisms are pretty well understood
why this happens. There are no exact
solution formulas but we understand why
this happens and this is what happens in
the real world. Slight changes remember
butterfly flapping its wings over the
Gulf of Mexico leads to a hurricane over
Texas, right? This the classic
description of chaos. So now so the the
the challenge is set. So this is where
the multiscale comes in remember and
these are linked to each other. If the
the chaos is what creates the multiscale
which induces further chaos which
induces the multiscale and so on. So
remember that this was the this was the
perspective that you have chaotic and
multiscale at least visually. Now you
see what is what is going on here. So
[snorts] what did we do now? So we have
studied all these different
architectures. We have studied all these
different AI models. So what we going to
do is we going to apply them. Okay,
we're going to apply them. It's a it's a
classic example. We have initial
conditions as your input. The solution
operator takes things forward in time.
We have time trajectories. So, we are
all set. This is cartisian grids. No
need to take graphs, transform. You
don't have to take you can take
transformers. There's no problem. But no
need to put in some very complex
geometry. We can take some simple
geometries. And what we did here is that
we combined CN O which is pretty good at
cartigian geometries right with some
parts of FN O. So we hybridized the
details are not important uh as you'll
see in the next slide. It doesn't matter
what what exact neural operator do you
take but we take a combination of them.
So just imagine that this is a hybrid of
CNO and FNO which combines local
convolutions which comes from CNO with
some global features which are due to
the FIA transform. Right? So it's a
combination of both. But what I'm saying
holds for every single operator. You can
take a vision transformer here. You can
take a scalable operator transformer
here. You can take anything else and
you'll get the same results. Okay. So
what do we see? We see two important
things. Remember that we have a
multiscale solution and it is going to
be chaotic. Now let's see whether we
manage that or not. You look here. So
what is the first thing that you see?
The first thing you see is that these
two things are so what is here and what
is here are completely different from
each other. Right? there there's no way
that these two things are being
approximated. And what you see is that
it's full of errors. This is like almost
100% point-wise errors, even bigger. And
what is important here is that the
structures are washed out, right? So
remember that the first one here has a
lot of small scale structures. This one
has no small scale structures. It has
some large scale edies, right? Large
scale structures that it's
approximating. No small scale structures
are being approximated. And it's not a
question of a bad architecture. All
architectures will do the same. Is not a
question of lack of data. We used about
a thousand trajectories and we trained
them in an alltoall manner. So there is
there is enough data. Maybe it's even
10,000 trajectories. I don't remember
exactly but orders of thousands of
trajectories. So you see that the
multiscale structure is not approximated
well at all. And what's also interesting
that we repeated the same experiment,
right? We changed this. We used the same
small random perturbations in each case.
And then what happened is you don't see
that at all. You see that it's the same
flow. It doesn't even see the random
pertations and you get up the same flow.
So this is really bad news, right?
Because what does it say that we
completely failed after all these
efforts that we have put in in
understanding neural operators and so
on. We completely failed in solving this
is this grand challenge. These are the
hardest kind of PTEs that as nonlinear
as it gets. It's in 3D. These are
systems of equations that are very
complex dynamics and we have completely
failed in approximating them with all
the neural operators that we have
learned so far. Right? Questions
have proven very successful in modeling
atmospheric flow.
>> They're very bad in modeling atmospheric
flows.
>> It's okay. So this is uh the myth that
people this is example atmospheric flows
are no different than this right this
toy model. So this is not true. See what
you can model is short-time behavior.
>> Okay?
>> Right? So if you have been given the
state of the atmosphere now and you want
to predict something in 3 hours, you can
do that because things have not changed
so much. But if you want to predict the
next day or 2 days hence, then you
cannot do that. Okay? So it's not true
that it's it's uh because you are making
short-term predictions. this is okay
because if not you'll see in the next
slide that there is a pretty clear
mathematical reason why this cannot be
done
yeah questions further questions no
everyone understood what the difficulty
is let's see why this happens right uh
you can say oh change the architecture
change the training strategy I will
argue that none of this is going to work
let's see why
Okay, so this was answered I would say
at least there are there are many
attempts particularly in the weather
forecasting community where they
understood that something is a miss but
formally it was done in this paper
[snorts] that I'm going to talk about it
comes from my lab with some people in
Google research uh so it was joint
effort between us so it's based on the
following idea and I'm going to walk you
through these steps very very slowly
okay so first thing that we should
remember is that my underlying operator
underlying map that I'm after all what
is a neural operator doing it's
approximating the ground truth right the
ground truth operator the first thing to
remember is that neural networks or
neural operators for that matter they
are neural networks except that they
take functions as inputs and outputs
these objects are universal
approximators so in principle you could
say hey since they're universal
approximators they can approximate any
continuous function what you're looking
at are continuous functions they are
pointwise continuous functions. So why
can't you approximate them? Means neural
if you have enough data and if you have
enough capacity you should be able to
approximate uh this with neural networks
right? So that's true neural networks
neural operators these are all universal
approximators. So in principle we should
be able to do this but in practice
remember that how do we learn? We we say
yes neural networks can approximate
functions but in practice given data we
use a gradient descent method and then
we try to approximate right we try to
take small gradient descent steps such
that we can match the data. So what does
this gradient descent imply? The
gradient descent implies and this we
have done in the tutorials. For
instance, whenever you need to train
with gradient descent, it's very very
important to have bounded gradients or
let's say that your gradients are of the
order of one need not be one but of the
order of one in the sense that if the
problem size increases, architecture
size increases, the gradient shouldn't
blow up, right? because otherwise you
end up with the exploding gradients
problem or the vanishing gradients
problem because if the gradients explode
they can't train. If the gradients
vanish then you can't train. So a lot of
the work in ML architectures is about
normalization so that the gradients are
well behaved you have residual
connections you have this you have that.
So you ensure trainability. So that's a
big aim for neural network architectures
and for optimization architectures that
you should try to make the gradients as
close to one as possible because when
you put different layers together powers
of one are close to one right but if
it's 0.2 or two then they can blow up
0.2 and two can blow down. So this is
important. Remember that the gradients
are going to be essentially of order
one. Since the gradients are going to be
essentially of order one, intuitively
what happens is that if the first
derivative is of the order of one,
clearly the lip shit's constant of uh
neural networks for any for trained
neural networks arbitrary neural
networks can have whatever values as
possible. But for trained neural
networks, this will also be of order of
one, right? because uh after all the
gradient is what controls the lip shit's
constant. So in principle the maps that
we are going to have are realized with
neural networks with neural networks
themselves are nicely behaved objects
trained neural networks. These [snorts]
maps people say that they and this has
been done empirically mostly not there
is not a lot of theory in statistical
physics there's a notion which is called
the edge of chaos. So edge of chaos says
that your gradients are not or your
sensitivity is not extremely small nor
is it extremely large. It is sort of at
the edge which means that your gradients
are of order one which is roughly what
is reflected from the training. So
because of this there's also some issue
of spectral bias. They are not uh good
at resolving high frequencies but this
is we don't even need that right. So
just based on this uh analysis that the
gradients or this observation rather
that because of training the gradients
are going to be well behaved because the
gradients are going to be well behaved
the lip shit's constant will be roughly
of the order of one. It could be 10 or
500 or 0.5 but it cannot be 500,000.
Right? So this means that essentially
neural networks are what we call as
insensitive.
What does insensitive means? It means
that if you have tiny tiny little
perturbations then uh the gradient with
respect to that perturbation is bound to
be small right otherwise uh so the and
is bound to be order of one rather than
of the order of a million. So because of
this neural networks cannot see tiny
perturbations because if they did see
tiny perturbations that would mean that
they would have very large gradients
which means that you cannot train them.
Okay. So essentially that's a hypothesis
means there's no sort of theory behind
this that stoastic gradient descent
cannot train perturbations but obser
observationally and the way in which
neural network architectures are
designed with normalizations and so on
this is a very realistic reasonable
hypothesis. So is this clear? So this is
the crux of my argument that you cannot
make neural networks train neural
networks observe tiny tiny
perturbations. Okay. And tiny
perturbations are the real issue here
because we have chaos, right? We have
sensitive dependence to tiny
perturbations. So neural networks are
right here. You give them a tiny
perturbations, they don't see it. Their
output train neural networks is going to
be close to what the mean essentially,
right? What you gave them. So now based
just on this hypothesis, I can make the
following conclusion. Now please uh pay
pay attention. So what am I trying to
do? My objective is if you remember in
the numerical experiment that we did we
looked at tiny tiny little perturbations
you'll see in the next slide that all
that we can hope for is estimating some
statistical quantities because
deterministic quantities are not even
well defined. So essentially my target
is that I take my ground truth and I'm
able to estimate somehow the
distribution of with respect to these
tiny perturbations. So I make tiny tiny
little perturbations and I'm going to
measure the mean and I'm going to
measure the valiance and all that I
require my learning problem or learning
architecture to be able to do is to be
able to approximate these things. Okay.
So now what is my target? I'm going to
put in these tiny perturbations and I'm
going to do some averages some
statistics over these perturbations.
Okay. And then I'm going to see whether
my neural network is able to resolve the
statistics correctly. Is that clear what
I'm going to do? So that is my training
at test protocol. Training is uh
different how you train. So okay so each
time when I'm testing or inferring with
my neural operator or neural network I
give it. So I have a base state. This is
my U bar star and then I do some
perturbations right. So this is the
idea. So I do these perturbations with
respect to U bar star. I feed it in the
neural network and I want to see what
the oh sorry I want to see what the
outputs are maybe I expand it even more
okay I want to see what the output is
going to be okay so now observe very
carefully what happens so if you look at
it [snorts]
this term here remains the same right
because we know that uh even if you make
tiny perturbations to the ground truth s
the solution operator s it doesn't mean
that it regresses to the mean. There is
a non-trivial effect of this tiny
perturbations right as you have seen
here up here you can see that uh why is
this
what happened now
is it okay now okay good so some so as
you can see that we make this tiny
pertibbations the ground truth doesn't
change so I cannot do anything with
respect to to the ground truth. But what
happens to the neural network? Remember
that the neural network doesn't see tiny
pertibations or neural operator doesn't
see the tiny pertibations. So this
regresses back to the ground state,
right? So it regresses back to the
ground state. This is just from this
insensitivity hypothesis and the fact
that your ground truth is sensitive. The
ground truth is sensitive. The neural
network is insensitive. So now we have
two terms here. So we can uh we can just
uh add and subtract and then it's a very
simple analysis. It's called a bias
variance decomposition. You can even do
it as an exercise. It's that simple.
Then we do this bias variance
decomposition which is essentially
expanding out an expon
expectation and looking at what is
independent and what is dependent.
That's all. When you do that you get two
terms. Okay. Term one here and term two
here. So let me try to explain what
these terms are so that uh you you
understand this. This is an exact
decomposition. It's not an approximation
or anything. It's exact. Okay. So let's
look at this term here. So remember my
neural networks are parameterized by the
parameter theta. Right? So and you look
at the second term here. There's no
theta sitting here at all. It's
independent of neural networks. It's
independent of the approximation. What
is this? this term is actually the
variance of these uh pictures that I got
here. So remember that these pictures
they are varying with respect to each
sample. So I can compute the variance
over this uh perturbations and this is
precisely this variance independent of
neural networks and this variance is
essentially order one. So this is due to
the due to the nature of the problem
itself. Okay, due to the nature of the
problem itself that it's chaotic. So you
have large variance even if you have
tiny perturbations and what's the
interesting thing is that because both
the terms are positive even if this term
was driven to zero you'd still get an
order of one which would mean that
whatever you do as long as your neural
network is insensitive your variance uh
of the ground truth will dominate and
you can never train this neural network
and this is what you see in practice
also that whenever we tried to train
these neural networks you know first we
tried to train them right and then we
didn't succeed we always got order of
one errors
then this is this is the mathematical
reason why the physical reason why this
happens okay so you can never be able to
train these neuronet networks even if
you are so what is the best that you can
do then the best you can do this is a
positive term right um
sorry I'm trying to expand things uh so
this is a positive term there's a square
here so best you can do is to go down to
zero so let's put it to zero so let's
put it to zero
And we when you put it to zero, 5 theta
is going to be equal to the mean. Right?
So this is nothing but the mean s of u
star plus delta u. Right? So what does
it say that the best you can do with
neuronet networks which are insensitive
which I argue are all neural networks is
that you can just approximate the mean.
Okay. And you cannot approximate the
variance at all. So if you and this is
exactly what happens. So because of the
nature everything regresses to the mean.
There's no variance in the prediction of
the neuronet network. And it so happens
for these problems that the mean itself
is not having small scales. The small
scales are washed out in the mean.
They're purely as a consequence of the
variance. This is sort of well known
from fluid dynamics from the physics of
turbulence and we don't even need to go
there. Right? So if there were these
small scales then anyway it would have
been hard for neural network to
approximate because of its spectral bias
but we don't even need to go there. So
what does this uh little bit of theory?
It's not very deep theory. It's based on
some straightforward uh hypothesis. It
already is able to tell you that
whatever you do in this regime, you
cannot approximate the statistics. This
is what you want to approximate. You
want to approximate the statistics. You
cannot do that. Okay. This is
impossible. Yes. Go ahead.
>> When [snorts] operator approximates the
mean, why is that not homogeneous all
over the domain? And why is why does it
happen?
>> It's not a mean over the domain. It's a
mean over the perturbations. So this is
a field, right? So it has some it's not
it's not a it's not a mean over space
and time. It's a mean just over the
probability distribution. That's why
it's heterogeneous. And it has a
meaning. You can write it out. In some
cases, you can even calculate it
explicitly. You can write down an
evolution equation of the mean. Uh it's
in terms of variance. It's not always
closed, but in some special cases, it's
closed. So you this is exactly how the
mean looks like also physically. So if I
took a mean of these guys [snorts] as
you'll see later I'll take a mean of
these guys. This is exactly what I'll
get. Okay for the questions. No [snorts]
so that's very bad news right? So it has
nothing to do with uh the architecture
itself. It has nothing to do with the
training process. It has to do with the
very nature of neural networks. Neural
networks are trained to keep your
gradients bounded. So how on earth can
they approximate maps which have
unbounded gradients? So this is sort of
a fundamental issue mathematical
physical issue that we have to confront
with in neural networks. Okay. But uh
that doesn't since I'm talking and I
have a long lecture to give. There must
be a solution, right? So the solution
comes through uh what can be done,
right? So what can be done is to
understand a few things. So this happens
remember that this is because of this
insensitivity hypothesis for for very
short time scales. This and this is the
question that someone one of you asked
why why would it might work for weather
because for very short time scales
this is not this might be true s of star
for short time scales so then it's okay
right because then anyway what you need
is some sort of mean behavior they can
approximate that but it's only on a over
longer time scales that that's why the
climate is unpredictable right only the
statistics make sense that it becomes
harder to make these approximations.
Okay. So what can be done? So what can
be done is to understand the nature of
the beast that we're confronting and
this comes from my previous avatar
essentially because I also work on
mathematical and computational fluid
dynamics. So the understanding is the
following and let me explain and then
after the break we are going to sort of
uh realize this in practice. So what can
be done is to give up the hope of being
able to match this very very complex uh
phenomena that are going on. So here is
an example. So this is the actual
initial conditions not of the yellow
green vortex but something called a
cylindrical shear flow. So this is the
initial conditions. I think we show the
vorticity here. You've seen these
pictures before. They come from a
probability distribution and this
probability distribution is almost a dra
right because we are making tiny tiny
little perturbations. So it's very sort
of narrow extremely narrow probability
distribution. Then you evolve it. Okay.
So the evolution operator is at least at
an approximation. You can do it with a
numerical method for instance and you
can go very large scale in the compute.
You can evolve it. So it starts forming
complex structures already for short
time you see that there is a separation
of the trajectories and over long times
they they don't look anything remotely
close to each other. Right? And in
addition the structures are very very
complicated. Just look at these tiny
tiny little details, tiny tiny little
vortices and so on. So these are very
very complex structures. So we have seen
this complex, multiscale, chaotic. So
these are the multiscale and chaotic are
the words that are there. So the idea is
and this is also based on some sound
mathematical and physical theory is that
there's no way on earth that these
operators are they're so complicated
that there's don't even try to match
every world every every vortex every
detail this every editing this is not
feasible at all what is feasible instead
is what is called statistical
computation so you can always compute
statistics because you have probability
distribution here so you can compute the
mean and the variance let's try to
evolve the mean and the variance Let's
try to evolve the mean and the variance
and the higher quantities you know
ktosis skuness whatever and these
probability density functions these
things are much better behaved there is
some mathematical grounds to that and in
particular as you evolve time the
probability distribution is a much
better defined quantity. It is what is
called a statistical solution. So
statistical solution uh to make it very
short is that you can only get the
statistics correct. This is the best
that you can hope for. There's no way
that uh every single world and vortex is
going to be matched but statistically
these things are going to make sense. So
here we did not even get the right
statistics because we did not get the
variance at all. Right? There's a order
of one variance and the variance here is
zero. So we didn't get the variance. So
it's not like we are doing the
statistics correct either. So the idea
is to realize that only statistical
computation is feasible. And this as I
said this there are many people working
on it but I have done a lot of work on
this so I know what's what's going wrong
here and then we realize that we will
never be able to match all these details
all these little worlds and vortices but
we can directly approximate a
probability distribution which is
actually what is called a conditional
distribution. So in this setting it is
only conditioned on the initial
conditions because the periodic boundary
conditions the equations these are fixed
all that we change the initial
conditions. So as the solution changes
in time the probability distribution so
this object here so this is just a
picture this is in infinite dimensions
right it's a probability distribution in
infinite dimensions that's a well-
definfined quantity under certain
reasonable assumptions and that is the
quantity that we are going to
approximate so instead of learning
individual samples so what were we
trying to do to approximate a
distribution we were taking uh some
inputs some initial we're sampling by
using Monte Carlo the probability space
of inputs. We are using the neural
operator, right? And then we are making
predictions and outputs and then staking
statistics. But we are essentially
trying to match each of these outputs uh
deterministically pointwise. And this is
impossible. The the you should look
around some flows and see how
complicated they are. The question that
we're going to do is can we sort of
short circuit this entire process? not
go through trying to match each of these
impossible to match chaotic maps but
directly go from learning one
distribution of giving one distribution
to another distribution or conditioning
or your output distribution or target
distribution on your input distribution.
So what can be done here is what is
called distributional learning.
In some sense all uh machine learning is
distributional learning but uh there are
some kind of machine learning that does
it exactly this which is generative
learning or generative AI and that's
what we are going to do after the break.
So let's take a short break. Let's meet
at 10 past and then we resume on how to
do it.
Yeah. So I have to hurry up to this.
Okay. So after the break I motivated why
we need to do distribution learning why
we need to learn conditional
distributions which also have these
properties of being able to deal with
fine scales or multiple scales. So
generative AI as I said is a way to go.
This is a structured way to learn
distributions and we know from Zora and
from Dali and so on that you can create
[snorts] very very sharp very very small
sort of scale multiscale images. This is
an example where tiny tiny details are
very nicely resolved. Right? So we know
that diffusion models in particular. Uh
and there are other ways but uh let me
focus on diffusion models for this uh
lecture. So diffusion models they can
generate images and videos with small
scale details. We know that. But the
question is can we sort of adapt them to
this domain? Can we provide them with
the physical correctness accuracy and
how do we add conditionalities because
that's the key right? So we need to do
conditional diffusion and this will also
be explored by David uh probably in the
very last lecture of the course where
he's going to talk about generative
design of uh of small molecules that can
act as drugs. So generative drug drug
design right? So let's start with the
idea of conditional distributions. What
does it mean to conditionally
[clears throat] to draw or sample from a
conditional distribution? Right? So this
is a typical example. This is very
common these days with large language
models. [snorts]
So you give a prompt and ask the image
generator for instance to generate image
and a prompt could be a fox looking for
a sock means something that has never
happened but uh then you can still
provide this and then the image
generator provides you with a lovely
image of a fox actually near socks right
so what has happened here so what you do
is that you have a input conditioning C
let's say it could be a vector it could
be a field whatever and this is your
prompt here so the prompt is tokenized
So essentially you're drawing a vector
and then what you do is you get a sample
from a conditional distribution which is
the image of a fox given a prompt or
image given a prompt. Right? So here the
conditionality is image given a prompt.
So again output or target conditioned on
an input distribution. And so in
principle this has been very effectively
done by these kind of models. And as you
can see here the question is how do they
do it? So the way is remember that we
are trying to learn target distribution.
Okay. So let me just give you some
general idea and then we realize it. So
objective is to learn a target
distribution.
So learn a target distribution.
The conditionality can always be uh put
in. Okay. So let's uh just look at it in
1D. So you want to learn a target
distribution uh in 1D. This could be a
complex biodal distribution something
like this. So this is your target
distribution PT but uh all these methods
and you know that all that you have
access to is a few samples from it
right. So you you do have some access to
some samples and then what you want to
do is and what people have done
historically in this domain is that they
go to a
uh okay let's do this. So this is like a
normal distribution. So this is a known
distribution.
Let me say PK for instance, right? And
the idea is that you should be able to
go from one to the other by what is
called uh measure transport or
distribution matching or whatever. So
there must be a mechanism by which you
can go from the target to the sort of a
known distribution. You can think of it
also as a prior if you're interested in
basian inference. But let's say you have
a target distribution which is unknown
but from which you can draw some samples
and you have a known distribution which
is uh from which you can draw as many
samples as you want. This is typically a
standard normal. So we know how to
sample from this distribution and the
idea is that somehow given these samples
of the target distribution there should
be a process by which you can go from
the target to the known distribution and
so that uh all that uh that we are doing
is during the training process we are
learning given the samples of the dist
target distribution how to go from the
target to the known distribution so that
at inference you just revert the process
okay so you say that I take something
non standard normal and then I'm able to
go back to the target distribution
because I know the forward process as
long as this process is reversible I can
do this and there are different ways to
do it the two most the first one that
was introduced was GANs or generative
adversarial networks where the
generator network and a discriminator
network were involved. Then came flow
matching uh which is one way to do it.
So you you move
[cough and clears throat] from
from your target distribution to your
known distribution through a flow,
right? Through a flow in the probability
space and then this flow is reversible
and the most popular these days are what
are called diffusion models where you
change it by using uh diffusion process.
Okay. So all of them can be sort of
repurposed for our needs. I will focus
for this lecture for concreteness on
diffusion models. Okay. But uh in
general to learn diffusion models is
like two three lectures in a generative
AI course. I'm going to try to do this
in 15 minutes which is a impossible task
right but uh this is the nature of the
beast. Uh we I just assume that you know
a little bit or you learn a little bit
about uh diffusion models independently
and also in the tutorial on Monday
bogdan is going to cover this. So at
least at a practical level you know what
is to be done but the basic idea is a
method by which you can transform a
target distribution into a known
distribution during training and during
inference you can go the other way. You
can sample from the known distribution
as an input and the output would be a
sample from the target distribution. So
how does a diffusion model do it? It
does it by it noising and denoising and
this is this is the basic basic idea
here. Okay, let me again give you some
intuition. The details are impossible to
convey in a short period of time. Okay,
so the idea is that remember so we have
to move between the target and a known
distribution and the known distribution
is typically a gausian
with a with some varian structure that
is known right noise essentially. So
what you do is that you add noise. So
intuitively you add noise iteratively.
So this is a step-by-step method. That's
why it's diffusion. You don't uh you
step byep method. You start adding
noise. You can see this one is a little
more noisy. This one is even more noisy.
Here it's more noisy and finally this is
noise. Okay. So you you are constantly
adding noise by some noise process means
the simplest noise process that you can
do is uh given uh a sample you just keep
on adding uh gausian noise iteratively
but usually this is done by using a
stoastic differential equation
and in the next uh slide I will tell you
the exact form of the stoastic
differential equation. So imagine that
you're adding this noise by solving a
stoastic differential equation. Okay,
you give some input and all that the
stoastic differential equation does is
that it keeps on adding noise but
because it's a differential equation you
do it iteratively over time. Now
thankfully stoastic differential
equations as many many classes of
differential equations are reversible.
Okay. So the second process which is on
this direction remember that I told you
that you go from the target to the known
by adding noise. So from the known to
the target you have to go by taking out
noise which is essentially denoising as
it is called and this doising is done by
solving a reverse stoastic differential
equation.
A reverse stoastic differential
equation. we will as I said I will write
down the process before and the yeah
this this we are going to look at later
in the in the lecture so there's a way
in which this noising and denoising
process one can train but I I'll focus
on the next slide okay so is the general
idea clear so you add noise so
essentially the method to add noise here
is to put in a stoastic differential
equation which will be the same or
adding noise is tantamount or is
equivalent to solving stoastic
differential equation forward in time.
So that taking out noise is solving a
stoastic differential equation backward
in time or a reverse stoastic
differential equation backward in time.
So at inference what you do essentially
is that given a gausian given a sample
of a gausian you throw it into the
stoastic differential equation and you
keep on solving it solving it solving it
iteratively till you get this beautiful
answer. Okay. And you can imagine that
during the training process, it has
there are no natural images out there
which is a fox looking for a sock,
right? So this has to somehow
interpolate between a sock and a fox and
put it together. So that's that's the
basic idea. But now we are not looking
at images. We are not looking at text as
a prompt. Our uh in conditional
distribution is over here. Let's say
initial conditions. uh is conditioned
upon the distribution and initial
conditions and our solution is given by
solution of a PTE or some physical
process. So we have to adapt this. I
know that this is a bit brief here but
are there any questions conceptually on
this noising and denoising process?
We'll see the details in a second but
just conceptually yes go ahead.
>> Was the conditioning actually done?
>> You'll see there's a there's a very
concrete way in which this is done.
Okay. you'll see that that you can I'm
just asking about the basic learning
unconditional distributions is the first
step right and this is where this
noising and denoising process works
further questions okay you'll have more
on the next slide because it's a very
very dense one as you can imagine
so let me so this is one particular
realization of this idea it's not the
only one but I still think it's uh at
least in this domain the most uh
the most accurate one it's the same
paper that I just mentioned before and
the algorithm is called gen CFT. It's a
generative algorithm for CFT. So we call
it as gen CFT we use conditional right
because we have to condition it on the
initial conditions or boundary
conditions for that matter. You'll see
that and it's a diffusion model but
there is a whole zoo of diffusion
models. Recently Stefano Armon who is at
Stanford and was one of the inventors of
diffusion models he released a survey
paper about diffusion models and it's
like 500 pages long you know so it's a
very very rich area and it didn't exist
4 years ago so this is uh this is how
the speed of progress is right so anyway
so this is a very big zoo it's
impossible to cover it so I'll I'll be
selective and within that class we will
choose what are called scorebased
diffusion models and I'll explain what
what those things are in a sec. So
remember that the key for us is the
noising process and the denoising
process right how do we noise how do we
den noiseise how do we put in the input
uh conditioning and how do we realize
everything so this slide essentially
answers all those questions but it does
it in a very condensed manner as it it
has to because I have to finish the
lecture today right it's sort of I don't
have time beyond this so noising process
is as I said solving a stoastic
differential equation and here this is
still Uh I just wrote it down for the
unconditional case. As you can see this
is unconditional. I don't yet have a
condition. The condition comes in later.
That's very very straightforward. So you
don't have to concentrate on the
mathematical details because this is
impossible in a in a short lecture. I
advise you to go read the paper or
better go to the tutorial on Monday
where some concrete examples are shown.
Right? But you have to just concentrate
on the basic ideas so that you
understand what's going on. So this is
my noising process.
We never actually solve this, right? We
never add noise by having solving a
differential equation. We just add noise
by adding noise. But it's tantamount to
solving this differential equation
because you need it to solve the reverse
differential equation. So essentially a
stoastic differential equation is like
an ordinary differential equation. If
you did not have the noise term, this
will be a simple ordinary differential
equation. This st is some given function
some given time dependent scaling
function so that things are scaled very
nicely you can think of it as uh t for
instance very simple so that this term
is just uh just a simple term so you
have a drift so drift is a linear drift
so it's a very simple object linear
drift uh that's what corresponds to
essentially causian type processes and
then you have a diffusion term which is
given by a brownian motion so yes go
ahead uh on the left hand side of this
equation. Should it not be du d?
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah, there are there
are many mistakes. I also saw that I'm
missing a log here. So when I put it
quickly, this is what happens. d of
course. So it's a change with respect to
u. I hope ah here it's at least correct.
So not everything is wrong. Okay. Sorry.
Yeah, sometimes these typos creep in
[snorts] especially when you're trying
to write in uh on a PowerPoint slide or
something, right? Okay, so this is dut
indeed. There is some drift term and
this is a diffusion term or the real
noise term, right? So and essentially
when you add based on this very simple
you can solve this explicitly. This is
uh loss of mcken formulation and you see
that it's just adding gausian noise from
a given standard normal distribution.
Okay. So the noising process if I give
it fluid flow all that it will do is if
I solve the stoastic differential
equation over time it will go to noise.
Okay. So this is a straightforward
process but the good thing about this is
that this stoastic differential equation
is reversible and the reverse stoastic
differential equation is here I just
missed. So can you please correct this
to a gradient of u log of v of u.
Okay, this is unconditional still. I
have not yet attached the
conditionality. I will do that in a sec.
And this is a log. I have missed a log
here. So you can you can do this. So you
this is a mathematical theory. It cannot
be explained in one lecture. It requires
several lectures to develop this. But
you just assume that there is this
mathematical theory which tells us that
given the it's it's not that difficult.
Right? So you can imagine if you have a
standard deterministic differential
equation, you start from the initial
conditions and you go to the final time
and then you can revert the process. You
can revert the dynamics as long as the
dynamics is reversible. And here with
stoastic differential equations is the
same story. And in this particular case,
the dynamics is indeed reversible. You
can guess what it is and then write
things down. So of course you have a
diffusion term which is as before and
this has to be solved backward in time.
But the key here is the drift term. So
the drift term is uh as before here but
you add these are some scale factors
based on the noise but what you add here
is this new term right so essentially
it's the same diffusion but the drift is
what is different and you add this
quantity here and p is your probability
density PDF of the target distribution.
So this is some not simple mathematics
but mast's level mathematics right. So
you can you can do this process. So what
does it say that if I had the noise
process given by my forward SD which is
given here then the reverse SD given by
this object here gives me the inversion
of the dynamics. So as long as I give it
some noise and solve this ST
approximately by Oiler Maruyama is the
usual method maybe you can do something
else you can go back to the you can
generate samples from the target
distribution. So this is uh watertight
you know there is no issue this can be
mathematically shown and so on but the
issue is that it involves a new term
right you have to you have to pay a
price and a new term is precisely this
gradient of u log p of u p is the
probability density function of the
target distribution of course you don't
know it right if you you only have
access to samples of it if you knew it
there would be nothing to be done mean
you know what the probability density
function is there is no closed form
solution to this and then you could do
it so this guy Here this whole thing is
what is called the score function.
And the whole sort of beauty of uh
diffusion models is how can we
approximate this score function because
if you know the score function we can
solve the stoastic SDE and we can
stoastic differential equation and we
can go back to the right samples and
this is here where the key idea comes in
and this comes from what is called Twi's
formula. I'm not I I will write down the
for maybe I can I can write down the
formula. There's no space here. Let me
give an extra page.
So remember that we have to approximate
the score function.
So score function.
Uh my notation is not perfect but it is
gradient of u log p right so log p of u
log is so p is a probability density
function. I'm sampling you
unconditionally but this can be easily
done conditionally. Okay. And this is
done by using what is called this is a
very very famous formula. It comes from
ma probability theory stoastic
differential equations. It's called
Tweed's formula.
Tweedy was a British mathematician. And
it says that you can approximate it
provided that you go through what is
called a dnoising process. So d of u
plus eta sigma
minus u I'll explain what these terms
are by sigma square
and this d is essentially what is called
a d noiser.
So what does this formula tell us? Means
this this can be proved. Again this is
all mathematically watertight. There is
no issue with this. This is some deep
mathematics. What it tells us is
something very very interesting. What it
says is now here I'm saying my target
distribution my known distribution is
always a gausian. Known is a gaussian
uh with uh at 0 sigma squ i. Right? So
this is my known distribution. So what
you do is the following. You start off
with uh let's say let's we are doing
things in 1D. Let us say that we
this is not a probability density
function but it's some features. Let's
say that this is my input U. I add noise
to this input. All right. I add noise.
So I take the [clears throat] input and
then I add some noise
and I keep on ah
what was that?
Okay. So I keep on adding noise
and keep on
why is that? Do you guys have any idea
why my
>> I think it thinks that you're cutting it
off and
>> ah
okay noise at largest scales.
[laughter]
Okay, you got you you got the idea. You
got the idea. Uh I've done it so many
times that uh I think maybe I make two
okay this one can't be okay something
like this and you keep on adding more
noise and then it will vanish you could
keep on adding more noise so now at
every noise level sigma uh sorry every
noise level ETA which is drawn from this
sigma all that you do is you demand that
you den noiseise the system okay so in
other words you've been given U plus ETA
as a the noisy version. This is a noisy
and what the deninoiser produces and
then you have the eta is the noise level
and if you give these two all that the
deninoiser will produce is d of u plus
eta eta which should be very close to
your u it will try to den noiseise okay
and when you do the den noising and if
you scale it properly you can
approximate the score function so this
is the genius this is this beautiful
idea from tweet's formula that people
can use. There are other ways to do it
but this is something which is very very
effective and this is what you can do in
order to sort of revert this process.
Okay. So this is totally independent. So
what is the training here about? The
training is take your samples from the
target distribution add some noise to
them gausian noise and just just make a
neural network den noiseise it right. So
this is keep on making a neural network
den noiseise it so that you can uh you
can form this deninoiser. Once you form
the deninoiser, you apply the deninoiser
and you can solve the tw's formula. So
what I've done here is that I have shown
you what happens when you apply the
deninoiser because there is a the u term
because remember that you apply the
tweed's formula and then it becomes the
deninoiser. Here already I put in the
conditionality because the
conditionality is just an additional
term to the deninoiser. You have the
drift uh you have the diffusion. You
have this drift term based on the
deninoiser d theta which is a neural
network. Again here neural networks are
universal approximators. So this
deninoiser function which removes noise
is just given by a neural network and
this is all that you have to do. So what
is the noise process and the denoising
process? So remember that at inference.
So there are two things here and it's
very in the next slide I have some
explanation uh for the training process.
All that I have to do is this one. I
just have to train the den noiser. So
what what is the meaning of that? So
given my noise level okay given my noise
level given my conditionality all that I
have to output is and given some
previous conditions for that matter all
that I have to output is a clean sample.
So right you have a lot of samples you
take the each of them add noise at
different levels throw it into the
deninoiser and ask the deninoiser to den
noiseise it by just minimizing the L2.
Right? So this is something that we have
learned plain vanilla neural networks
this can be done once this is done what
you do is you have a train deninoiser
this is the the exact architecture is
written in this slide but this is not
important so you have this train
deninoiser put it into the STE start
with this and you have the
conditionality which is already attached
to it and then solve this STE backward
and each time you need to solve the STE
you need to call the denoiser right
because it's one of the terms in the STE
But the deninoiser is already trained.
You just put it in and do this. Okay. So
this was uh diffusion uh scorebased
diffusion in 2 minutes but uh this the
best I can do and in the tutorial I have
explicitly asked him to explain this in
code. Okay. So that you can you can
understand what is done at a coding
level during training how do you train
the deninoiser and during inference how
do you solve the STE given the trained
deninoiser. So these are completely
different from what you have learned so
far. So what you have learned so far is
during the training you take a neural
network do a forward pass match with the
output and then uh put it into gradient
descent right and then train it here
it's very different here the training is
you somewhat similar the target is a
noised uh the target is a dinoised
version and the input is a noised
version so this is very similar but the
inference is now very very different
because in inference you can't just use
the neural network once you have to use
the neural network repeatedly when
you're solving the stoastic differential
equation. Okay, so this is sort of the
basic structure. You can learn more
about this on the tutorial on Monday
when he's really going to demonstrate
this. [snorts]
Now for our particular purposes, we used
we chose a architecture for a dinoiser.
I mean there are different choices you
can use fo CNO whatever we used
u so this is a vision transformer but uh
it has some convolution blocks. So it
starts it's like a CNO combination of a
CNO and a transformer. So here is a
convolution. Here's a convolution. It
has this uh upsampling down sampling
layers. You know that very well. And the
at the bottom here is a transformer. So
this is attention
because this is another way of reducing
the complexity. You have to apply
attention somewhere. So you apply it
only in the what is called the
bottleneck layer where you have
downsampled quite a bit. But this is a
detail means other other deninoisers
work equally equally well. So remember
during the training all that the
deninoiser does is given a noisy input
and given a clean output it tries to
match the clean output. During inference
it goes through an SDE and then keeps on
calling the calling the [clears throat]
deninoiser and solving the SD
iteratively. Okay. And this is what is
summarized here. Uh you can ask me
questions afterwards. So as I said now
there is conditionality each time you
also provide the initial conditions
noising you see what it is and this is
the den noising this is the training
process so given the input given the
noisy sample you apply to the vit so
that you can get the clean sample okay
and then you apply it to the reverse STE
or score based STE oil maruyama and you
can you can update it okay so this is
sort of the basic basic [clears throat]
structure that that we are going to use
questions no too much
okay you need to digest it okay anyway I
can uh you can also ask me afterwards
it's not a problem or also during the
next lecture because this is probably
technically the hardest part of the
course and what this will again be
revisited so there's a tutorial that you
can uh you can you can go to on Monday
please try to go to the tutorial and on
top David uh uh will teach also
diffusion but he's going to do it on a
graph doesn't matter but the basic idea
is exactly the same and he will do it at
the very last uh lecture that is on the
18th or 19th or something okay good now
this is the algorithm right so the
algorithm is very clear it's a it's a
more or less a straightforward uh
diffusion process which is used for
image generation these days even for
LLMs people are using diffusion LLMs
which is basically the same idea that
you noise and you den noiseise Right.
Now the question
>> where what was that?
Okay.
You had a question or no?
>> Um
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I was thinking about like
then [snorts] sure not sure if it's very
relevant like just asking like which
parameters from here are learned by the
machine and which one are
hyperparameters and whether those we
sort of take from the statistical
properties of the flow or length. So the
hyperparameters are exactly the same as
hyperparameters of a traditional sort of
regression based learning because there
you just it's a neural network or neural
operator for that matter the input to it
this neural operator is going to be a
field a 3D field in this case we also
have time another 3D field the initial
condition and we also have some lead
time and then the output is simply going
to be the clean sample so we have access
to the clean and the noise level right I
keep on also forgetting the noise level.
So these are your inputs. Uh given a
clean sample, you create the noise. So
you know what is the noise level. You
have the noisy sample. You put it into
the neural network and you try to match
the target. So there there is nothing
fancy which is going on right because
the noise levels there is a noise
schedule uh which is fairly standard
means different kinds of noise schedules
can be used but uh there's a noise
schedule. So that that could be one
additional at inference. [snorts] uh you
have to say the number of steps in the
STE what is the time step there are a
couple of hyperparameters but this is
not uh there's no training with respect
to these hyperparameters you just see
how well they do at inference
okay so there's not a the training is
more complicated because there's lot
more to train so these are expensive
models right because for each uh time
step for each sample uh if you want to
do all to all training for all these
pairs you have different noisy how
noise iterations you're going to add. It
could be 10, it could be 100 depending
on what sort of compute that you have.
So it's more expensive. These models are
more expensive to train. But that
doesn't mean that the training process
itself is any different from what you
have learned. Right? The inference is
different because now you have to solve
a earlier it was like doing a one step
forward pass is like a one step but now
there are uh I think we can do it with
eight steps sometimes you know but in
practice we do with 32 steps I think. I
don't remember exactly the number. So
this is something these details will be
given on on Monday by bogdown. So why
should this work? Okay. So we have
learned all these things. Um this is of
course it can learn distributions and so
on. But the fundamental problem that we
had is that we have not gone out of
neural networks. We are still using a
neural network and we are using a neural
network to learn a sensitive map. Right?
Because uh that that's all that we are
we are still doing. Why should this
work? It turns out that this is really
for tweeters because our objective if
you recall I took this detour into
diffusion models [snorts]
but our objective was to learn this
conditional distribution right. So given
uh perturbation you evolve the ground
truth and then you take statistics or
expectations or variance and so on over
this right now let us see whether this
pans out with all this uh insensitivity
hypothesis and so on. So now remember
that our loss function is different. So
this is the only difference from before.
Earlier we had a regression type loss
function. Now it's a den noising denoise
a training objective or denoiser loss
function. So what do we provide?
We provide the ground truth as the
initial conditions. Uh no not the
initial conditions. We provide the
ground truth. We add noise and we
provide the noise distribution and the
noise level. [clears throat] Right? And
all that the deninoiser does is that it
tries to match the ground truth. So
remember that we still have the
insensitivity hypothesis. Right? So the
ground truth nothing changes for the
deninoiser on the other hand this a
neural network. So it cannot see small
perturbations. Remember that. So this
input of the deninoiser it cannot see
this. It can see right because now
remember that I have been giving it the
output. Earlier it was there was no
output. Now we have giving it the output
with some noise. So this part nothing
changes. It sees this. It sees this
without the noise, right? Because
without the little perturbation on top
and it sees this. Now what we can do is
we can do some analysis. We can set this
guy equal to U and do a change of
variables. Okay. So when we do a change
of variables, this term becomes a U plus
ETA. This becomes a U star as before.
Sigma and U. So we do a change of
variables. we recover this and instead
of this d of u you can say that this
becomes a probability density function
over u. So what happens now is that the
denoiser training objective is
mathematically shown that it can learn
the target distribution. So this
corresponds to this guy exactly. Okay.
So it is a fortuitous combination that
because remember that in a in a
traditional neural network you give the
input the initial conditions you give a
tiny perturbation and you ask it to
match the output but remember that it
was not able to match the output because
it didn't even see the difference in the
input. So how on earth is it going to
match the output? Now you're giving the
output which is this crazy map right but
with a little bit of noise. You're
giving the input. It might not see the
input but it sees the effect of the
noise in the input. It might not see the
noise in the input but it affects the
sees the effect of the small
perturbation in the output and then it
tries to den noiseise it. So we have
changed the perspective and it's only
because of this change of perspective
that we are able to match the
conditional distribution. So this is
people who invented diffusion models
they didn't have they didn't [music]
have to consider this at all. But it is
a fortuitous coincidence that it fits
exactly in what we want to do. And in
fact in the paper we sort of formalize
this arguments and we improve it end to
end but for some toy models but just by
looking at these arguments you see by
changing perspective from a regression
based model to a diffusion based
objective we are able to put in the
effect of this highly sensitive chaotic
maps because those highly sensitive
chaotic maps are still given as my input
to the neural network but with a little
bit of noise added and all that the
neural network learns is to remove the
noise and then it's able to recover the
noise, recover the thing during the
training. So is this clear? So this at
least you should be able to follow that
it's uh that this is sort of tailor made
for this kind of setting. Now let me
sort of quickly run through some results
so that whether this so mathematically
it seems that it it works but to make it
work is very different. And now let's uh
this is the moment of truth. So let's
see. [snorts]
So now this is the Turing time for a
Turing test, right? Let's see. So it's
very clear that this was my traditional
machine learning CFNO neural operator.
Why should we criticize CFNO? This is
neural operator. One of this is the
ground truth and one of this is the Gen
CFD model, the diffusion model. Who can
who can manage to say which one is the
ground truth and which one is the Gen
CFD model? That's why I didn't put the
legends you can say. Okay, go. I vaguely
remember the features from the top
[laughter]
but I guess the second row is the um
ground truth.
No, it's that's why [laughter]
no one can distinguish, right? That's uh
that shows that the model really worked
because there is the first row is the
ground truth because you cannot remember
the small features. No human can do
that. [laughter]
But the point is that it is not about
because we're not matching the exact
numbers anyway. We just want to get the
qualitative picture correct. Right? And
this is the ground truth. This is uh GT.
This is gen CFT and the main point that
we can see is that it has the small
scale structures. They are very
different, right? They shouldn't be the
same. You're not trying to match the
many many people still don't understand
this basic thing that we're not trying
to match this every single detail
deterministically. We are only trying to
match the distributions and then of
course it starts uh putting in some a
the qualitatively it's correct right it
has the variance it has the small scale
structures it was able to do that and
you guys none of at least you failed the
Turing test right because no human can
remember this is beyond human cognition
to be able to remember exactly and I've
even shown it to my friends who work on
turbulence for many many years
eventually they are able to figure out
because there is some smoothing but it
takes them a long time. So this really
does its job and you can see it very
clearly when you show the vorticity
because the vorticity if you remember we
we have seen this object uh this beast
before the vorticity is a curl of the
velocity.
It's a gradient right it tells you how
how vertical because the gradient is
divergence and vorticity the sort of
combination the flow is divergence free.
So all the information about the
gradient is in the vorticity. So again
it's the same structure. So these are
even smaller structures. Ground truth
gen CFT neural operator.
So again this is the now you know the
setting. So new operator was not able to
approximate the small scale structures
as you can see again visually to the
eye. Here you can see that little bit of
the structures are lost um because it
never sees the voticity right it's only
looking at the velocity and it's going
to make this. But here for instance it's
even better. some of the structures are
better attenuated. So again to the
eyeball this this really works but what
we can really check are things like the
mean. So let's just focus on this. So
the mean is correctly approximated. This
is the mean which is correctly
approximated. [snorts] This one doesn't
do such a bad job with the mean. You can
see that it approximates the mean fairly
well. The the traditional uh FNO or CNO
they are able to approximate the mean as
we expected. Not 100% there are still
errors. This does a much better better
job of approximating it. But at least it
is uh it is what it is. But the key is
the variance because here there is no
variance. So this is zero variance
and you can see that this approximates
the variance almost exactly. But this is
the whole point. Remember that we have
statistical computation. So at a minimum
you should be able to match the variance
and this is what what it does. Uh this
is also very interesting because these
are the point PDFs. What does it mean? I
take a single point in my flow. These
are two different points. And I look at
uh there are all these samples that we
have generated. And we look at the
probability density function of just one
of the components of the velocity I
think or these are two different
components
are there. So this is u u ux the x x
component
y and the z components and these are
really spread out right for different
samples. You see that at each point if
I'm sitting at a point different
realizations of the flow lead to very
very different results. So this is
completely spread out and the diffusion
models are able to capture the spread
very well. With the deterministic model
you keep on hitting the same value again
and again and again because you're just
approximating the mean. So you see how
beautifully the diffusion model is able
to approximate this. Right? So this was
this was quite impressive and it does it
by taking large steps. you know, we
don't have this tiny tiny steps that you
can potentially take. That's not chaotic
anymore. We really have a chaotic system
here. Uh the last point was the spectra.
The spectra tells you how much and this
is the interesting one.
Uh yeah.
Yeah. So let's let's look at this
spectrum. So this is in log plot I
think. Yeah. So this tells you that um
there are a lot of small scales. It goes
all the way for two orders of magnitude
here or three orders of magnitude and
you get all the small scales correct.
But what you don't get uh with a
traditional model is the small scales.
It only gets the large scales to some
extent and the rest uh it simply is not
able to get right. So this is this is
very clear because it always regresses
to the mean. The mean does not have this
have these features. And finally some
quantitative measures. So all these are
summarized here but the quantitative
measures are quite interesting. So you
have the mean error which is uh the
these are not very different from each
other. It's like 0.15 0.2 the
architecture itself UIT didn't do such a
good job but uh FNO or CNO did did quite
a good job. But here you see that both
for the standard uh deviation as well as
for some distributional measures these
things were very very poor and with this
model you were able to get it down by a
factor of 20 here and by a factor of 10
here. So you get the right statistics
there's some evaluation protocol I think
Bogdan is going to talk about that but
uh we are able to sort of match the
statistics both qualitatively as well as
quantitatively which is and this was not
done before means no one no one is able
to do this but we understood how this is
this is to be done and of course once
you have done this you can go to real
world flows nothing stops us so these
are three different almost real world
flows this is a smoke coming out of a
chimney and nozzle flow exact solution.
This is what the gen CFT gives. Does not
match every single world and vortex not
supposed to. And this is what your
traditional neural neural networks do.
[snorts]
They are not able to approximate it at
all. They just get the central jet.
Right? Uh this is how the variance is
approximated again more or less
perfectly.
This is a very interesting flow. This is
shock waves and turbulence. So shock
turbulence interaction explosion. If you
have a nuclear explosion for instance or
a volcanic eruption, this is what what
is going to happen again [clears throat]
means you can see that the shock wave is
approximated even by the traditional
neural operator but it is in this region
that uh gen CFT does a very very good
job uh in the variance as you can see
and the traditional neural operator is
not able to do that. And the last one is
an atmospheric flow. It is what is
called a dry convective boundary layer.
Again with the neural operator you have
no chance. This is uh things rising up
and falling down up updrafts and
downdrafts in the atmosphere dry
atmosphere and with the neural operator
you are able to almost match it. So it
it really has worked in every single
flow that we have attempted it. And the
advantage of course is the time right
because with the traditional methods if
you use a CPU it takes about 13 14 hours
to run this for instance and with our
algorithm it takes 4 seconds. Okay it's
not 10 milliseconds because you have
many many steps now in the in the solver
it's a 3D problem. It takes a long time
to train but once it is trained at
inference it's 3 4 seconds. Right? So
this is this is the target and we are
able to solve this very very complex
very sort of multiscale physics right
and this is uh for a toy model maybe I
can skip it or maybe I can just describe
what is going on so that you understand
it better so this is a toy model which
is [clears throat] it's not about PDS or
anything it's just about functions in
one dimension so you start off with some
mean function and you keep on adding
perturbations you add perturbations at
one scale at uh 10 times smaller scale
and five times even smaller scale and in
the statistical limit you have a lot of
small scale features. So that's the
deterministic map right and when you use
a traditional neural network just MLP in
this case there's nothing nothing fancy
what happens is that when you have small
perturbations like not a lot of fine
scales it does a very good job but as
soon as this is with 50 epochs I think
and this one is with 500 epochs
okay so with 50 epochs it is able to
match the the largest perturbations uh
quite well but as soon as you go to
smaller perturbations, it just
completely fails. But with 500 epochs,
it's able to match the second second
one. So it it starts adding as you as
you give it more and more training, it
keeps on adding more and more features,
but eventually at some level uh it it
realizes that it cannot match and the
best answer that it can get is to revert
to the mean. Right? So this is exactly
the behavior that we see with a
diffusion model. It's actually very very
interesting. So diffusion model, it
starts by adding. So here it behaves
exactly like a standard neural network.
But here what it does is that it just
adds noise. It fills it in. It assumes
that everything is noisy. It's not able
to den noiseise. Here it starts removing
noise. So it's able to match the ground
truth quite well except in this region.
And in these cases it realizes that it
will never be able to match every single
saw tooth. So it just provides you the
distributional outcome which is correct.
Right? So it's sort of toy model to
explain how diffusion models work. They
are very very different. So when you
train them too little they will just
give you the noisy distribution. When
you train them after a long time they
realize that they cannot match and they
just produce a noisy version with the
correct statistics. Right? That's why
they don't lose the small scale
information. So it's very very
interesting and this is just beginning.
Right? These papers are like less than a
year old. almost all the papers in this
area. [snorts] So whether it's fluid
flows or structural mechanics, material
science, inverse problems, UKQ, many of
these problems fall into the category
where there are multiscale solutions and
there's sensitive dependence on input.
So this is the chaotic part, right? And
diffusion models are sort of tailor made
for all of them mean uh people people
are slowly sort of starting to explore
this. But diffusion models are just one
part of Gen AI toolkit. any distribution
learner in principle could work. So we
have tried normalizing flows, rectified
flows, there are different flow matching
methods which also work but diffusion
model seems to be the ones which match
the best. Okay. So I think that was
quite yes
on the distribution.
>> This is uh it's a very very good
question means uh which can be asked
about any machine learning model
actually all the evaluation here is done
in some sense out of distribution. So
this is this micro micro setup that I
didn't have time to explain. So what we
do is that we have a training set right
but at inference we don't uh so training
set is based on taking large
perturbations. So you take some base
flow and you take very large
perturbations on that flow and you learn
how the how the solution behaves and so
on. But at inference we take one of
these uh guys and we take tiny tiny
little perturbations. Okay. and the
neural network has never seen this dy
little perturbations. So it's really
tested out of distribution already here.
Okay. But of course if you have uh let's
say that you train on this and you want
to approximate this there's no chance
right it's not it's not going to work
without some fine tuning for instance.
So out of distribution uh if it's close
by the distributions it will do a good
job. If it is not close it won't do a
good job. In fact, this out of
distribution is really the topic that we
are going to address uh in the next
lecture. So you'll see that uh out of
distribution sample complexity how this
is to be done is uh but there's no free
lunch there's no way something that has
been trained on text is going to use
work on images right so it's the same
you cannot you there are some domain
adaptation methods but I don't see them
as being game changers here okay so with
that let's uh meet next week and that
will be my last lecture of the course
but uh David is going to talk after that
so ciao to people on zoom